hi guys I'm great I'm John right now I
felt this opportune time moment to okay
to express gratitude for a certain man
man named Barry Barry you guys might
know from the couch tomato channel he's
a brilliant channel but I'm here to talk
about the man himself his channel is
very unique his main hook is like 24
reasons why this movie and this movie
are the same and a lot of time it's
really funny but a lot of the time too
it's like these movies are very similar
ya know be like guys are very much of
the same movie he does like child's play
2 in Toy Story 3 not only they were like
the same movie there he actually came
over a few months ago when I was going
through a rough patch some of you might
call it we all might recall Barry came
over he flown in from Florida to collab
with people and he came over and
honestly like I just spent the first
like two hours just talking with the guy
i didn't like film anything with him
like we just had like a real guiding i
talked for like 2-3 hours and then we
filmed that was just so out of it during
the video that I was like there's no way
i can post this and I'm sorry about that
John gotta know Barry too yeah he's
[ __ ] awesome there is a red guy
beyond his channel being amazing you get
to know this guy and you see what like
the guys like a family guy something
family guy not in my town family yeah
and like I get the sense that Barry like
lived he's older than us then seen if he
doesn't come across that way no you
don't got my youthful he has exact it's
weird when you like talk to him after
hearing is you never see his face in the
videos then he would hear him and it's
like trippy cuz I'm like you sound
exactly the same things you do further
video the guy's really artistic homes
let's just um she's a really optus never
tell you guys really artistic he writes
a lot like his main thing is screenplay
writing and he's a passionate dude
he's a responsible guy to you know he
has goals he's motivated he's really was
actually a really inspiring yeah I'm
hanging out with the guy because of his
lifestyle who he thought about things
how he felt towards things who he cared
about who how he felt hurt himself he's
a thoughtful dude yeah and he had a lot
of great advice like a lot of amazing
advice that I needed at the time I think
truly did help out in the end what he
went out of his way a lot of times to
show yeah just to be cool did to really
be appreciative just well what I did was
I introduced him to mark hamill late
this most owed guy or I guess that's a
competent he said the schmoes know was
like his biggest thing and he loves them
loves them and then I so I gotta
introduce him to Mark Ellis yeah and so
I did a kind thing to some Mel so now
you're seeing a ward hey John it's not
about awards it's about oh yeah we're
gonna get a video out or maybe a few
thousand people hear about the kind of
Eden where is it oh yeah so before Barry
left he's staying with someone who can
make things and he had his friend make
this for us and it's it's a 1 million
subscriber plan 1 million subscribe 1
million subscribers yeah and I'm very
grateful towards the guy more than just
give a shout out to bury I just wanted
to say like dude it's a long way overdue
thank you yeah way overdue
acknowledgement I really hope you guys
do go check out his channel because it
would make me feel good knowing that
people are going to support a guy who is
genuinely a great human being oh ya know
like it's guys like a real human being
you know crazy real sweet guy cuz I mean
like you got to you have to spend a lot
more time with him than I did and even
so like he was still really gregarious
and really you know keep good anyway ah
that's my name it's your full name
gregarious album he went out of his way
you know to even make me feel included
you know to me
connection it was like it was real nice
you know I felt no real good around
Barry hey I've been dude 1 million
subscribers whoo it's our catchphrase it
is we came up we came up with them no
one else has said if you can find one
person by one video where someone says
that and and declares that that is their
catchphrase and no one else has said it
this will be the first video that says
that in fact not just one send us every
video subscribe you a to the real
rejects John Humphrey is John the
reasons to Jerry on the John's of the
way talons John's a strong supporter of
Mel Gibson speaking Mel Gibson
facebook.com slash blue mouse I social
media manager girl over there